>> Tucker: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
IT'S FRIDAY.
WE ARE THRILLED TO BE ABLE TO
OPEN THE SHOW TONIGHT WITH RARE
GOOD NEWS.
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN VERY OFTEN.
WHEN IT DOES WE CELEBRATE.
ONE OF THE MAIN PROBLEMS WITH
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT THERE IS NO
WAY TO KNOW WHAT IT'S DOING.
YOU ARE NOT AX LOUED TO KNOW.
MORE THAN A BILLION FEDERAL
DOCUMENTS ARE CLASSIFIED AND
OFF-LIMITS TO YOU AND ALL OTHER
AMERICAN CITIZENS WHO DON'T WORK
FOR THE GOVERNMENT -- NO MATTER
WHAT YOU HEARD THE POINT OF THE
SYSTEM IS NOT TO PROTECT THE
COUNTRY FROM FOREIGN
ADVERSARIES.
THE POINT IS TO TAKE POWER OF
THE VOTERS AND THE OFFICIALS
THEY ELECT AND HAND THAT POWER
TO THE BUREAUCRACY IN
WASHINGTON.
IT'S DANGEROUS.
FOR ONCE WE CAN REPORT SOME
MEANINGFUL PUSH BACK AGAINST
THIS DECEIT.
KEVIN MCCARTHY BECAME SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE LAST FRIDAY.
HE IS PLEDGEING TO LET AMERICANS
SEE "ALL THAT HAPPENED AT THE
U.S. CAPITAL ON JANUARY 6TH,
2021.
THAT MEANS RELEASING 14,000
HOURS OF SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE
FROM DAY THAT HAS REMAINED
HIDDEN.
>> I THINK THE PEOPLE SHOULD SEE
IT.
I WATCHED WHAT NANCY PELOSI DID.
SHE POLITICIZED IT.
THE FIRST TIME IN THE HISTORY AS
A SPEAKER NOT ALLOWING
A MINORITY TO APPOINT TO
A COMMITTEE.
TO PICK AND CHOOSE.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
SHOULD SEE WHAT HAPPENED INSTEAD
OF A REPORT WRITTEN FOR
A POLITICAL BASIS.
I WANT TO BE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT IT
BUT YES, I AM ENGAGE TO DO THAT.
>> Tucker: WELL, YEAH.
AFTER 2 FULL YEARS AFTER HIGHLY
POLITICIZED CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEE AND GRAND STANDING IN
THE MEDIA AND UNPRECEDENTED
POLITICAL CRACKDOWN AND 1,000
ARRESTS, AMERICANS HAVE A RIGHT
TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY
6TH.
THAT'S WHAT KEVIN MCCARTHY SAID.
WHO COULD ARGUE OTHERWISE?
WHAT IS THE COUNTER ARGUMENT?
WELL, THERE IS ONE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN MAKING IT IN
COURT.
THE FOOTAGE FROM THAT DAY IS
STILL HIDDEN.
A QUOTE FROM A BRIEF FILED IN
A FEDERAL COURT BY A LEFT WING
U.S. ATTORNEY NAMED PHILLIPS:
SO THAT'S IT RIGHT THIS.
YOU CAN'T KNOW WHETHER THE
CAPITOL'S SURVEILLANCE CAMERAS
TILT OR ZOOM.
IF YOU DO KNOW, AMERICA IS IN
PERIL.
IT'S ABSURD.
EVERY HUMAN MOVEMENT IN THE
UNITED STATES CAPITOL IS
RECORDED BY CAMERAS.
THE SAME IS TRUE IN EVERY PUBLIC
BUILDING.
THAT'S NOT THE SECRET THE
DEMOCRATS IF HE WERE YOU MIGHT
LEARN IF YOU SAW THE TAPE.
THEY ARE MORE CONCERNED WHETHER
YOU WILL DISCOVER HOW MANY LAW
ENFORCEMENTS AGENTS HELPED
PROTESTORS ENTER THE BUILDING.
WE HAVE THE TAPE.
>> POLICE ARE SHOUTING AT
PROTESTORS.
THEY JUST BREACHED THE CAPITOL
AGAIN.
>> Tucker: THE BARRICADES CAME
DOWN.
IT WAS NOT THE POLICE WHO TOOK
THEM DOWN.
WE DON'T KNOW THE IDENTITY OF
THE PEOPLE WHO DID.
WHY DON'T WE WITH?
JULIE REPORTED -- THE MAN WHO
HAS HIS FEET ON NANCY PELOSI'S
DESK ON JANUARY 6TH.
A POLICE COMMANDER ADMITTED THAT
AGENTS WERE LEAPING THE CROWD.
HERE'S THE EXCHANGE:
AND CONFIRMED THEY WERE HIGHLY
TRAINED VIOLENT PEOPLE WHO
WORKED TOGETHER AND COORDINATE
TOGETHER.
THAT'S A REMARKABLE ADMISSION
BUT WHO WERE THESE PEOPLE.
UNDER OATH THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI REFUSED TO DENY THEY WERE
WORKING WITH FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR THAT FBI AGENTS
DRESSED AS TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
>> CAN YOU NOT TELL THE PEOPLE
WE DIDN'T HAVE AGENTS DRESSED AS
TRUMP SUPPORTERS INSIDE THE
CAPITOL?
>> YOU SHOULD NOT READ ANYTHING
INTO MY DECISION NOT TO STAIR
INFORMATION.
>> HIS TIME EXPIRED.
>> Tucker: THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
IT'S OBVIOUS THE FBI DID HAVE
SOURCES DRESSED AS TRUMP
SUPPORTERS INSIDE THE CAPITOL.
WE AS AMERICANS HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW.
HOW MANY FBI AGENTS PARTICIPATED
IN THE JANUARY 6TH RIOTS?
WHY CAN'T WE KNOW?
THERE IS NO GOOD REASON.
FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER WRAY
WANTS TO KEEP THE FOOTAGE HIDDEN
SO WE CAN'T KNOW.
THE SECRET IS NOT WHERE THE
CAMERAS IN THE CAPITOL, PAN,
TILT OR ZOOM.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
THE REAL SECRET IS WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED THERE.
FOR 2 YEARS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOUGHT THE RELEASE OF
THIS FOOTAGE.
SOME OF THAT FOOTAGE HAS
EMERGED.
LOOK AT THIS TAPE.
RELEASED ONLY AFTER A FEDERAL
JUDGY REJECTED THE DOJ'S CLAIM
THAT THIS FOOTAGE NEEDED TO STAY
SECRET ON NATIONAL SECURITY
GROUNDS.
IT COVERS A 15 MINUTE PERIOD ON
JANUARY 6TH FROM 2:25 TO 2:40
P.M. EASTERN TIME.
2:26 WAS WHEN MIKE PENCE WAS
EVACUATED FROM THE CAPITOL.
THIS SHOWS PEOPLE TAKING
PICTURES.
NOT MUCH OF A RIOT.
THE DOJ IS CHARGING SOME OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ENTERED THE CAPITOL
WITH ENDANGERING THE SAFETY OF
MIKE PENCE.
THEY SAID THE CAPITOL WAS
RESTRICTED BECAUSE MIKE PENCE
WAS PRESENT.
IT DOESN'T APPEAR FROM THAT
FOOTAGE THAT IT'S TRUE.
WHERE WAS MIKE PENCE AT THE
TIME?
PEOPLE ARE DOING JAIL TIME.
BUT WE CAN'T VERIFY IT BECAUSE
THE SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE IS
CLASSIFIED.
WE SHOULD SEE IT.
THAT FOOTAGE MIGHT SHOW WHEN THE
CAPITOL POLICE OFFICERS BEGAN
CPR ON THE TRUMP SUPPORTER WHO
DIED THAT DAY.
WE MIGHT LEARN WHERE A PERSON
WAS WEARING A MAGA HAT AS HE
COORDINATED WITH PROTESTORS.
AND THE GUY IN THE VIKING HAT,
HIS ACTIVITIES DURING JANUARY
6TH.
HE IS SERVING ALMOST 4 YEARS
BEHIND BARS FOR DECLINING
A POLICE OFFICER'S HALFHEARTED
REQUEST THAT HE TAKE THE PARTY
ELSEWHERE.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU GUYS.
[BLEEP].
GOD BLESS YOU.
>> I AM GOOD.
>> [RADIO CHATTER].
>> SOME KIND OF PLASTIC BULLET.
>> THIS IS THE SACREDEST PLACE.
>> Tucker: MORE THAN HALF OF ALL
MURDERS IN THE UNITED STATES ARE
NOT SOLVED BECAUSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN'T GET ITS ACT
TOGETHER TO SOLVE THOSE MURDERS.
THAT GUY HAS HAD HIS LIFE
DESTROYED AND IS SPENDING 41
MONTHS IN PRISON.
WHY?
DID HE DO SOMETHING WE ARE NOT
AWARE OF?
THE SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE WOULD
SHOW US AND ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
BIG PICTURE:
IF YOU DON'T WANT ANOTHER
JANUARY 6TH AND AVOID ANOTHER
RIOT, YOU WANT AS MUCH OF THE
FOOTAGE TO COME OUT AS POSSIBLE.
INSTEAD OUR GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
USING THE INFORMATION BLACKOUT
NECESSARY FOR NATIONAL SECURITY
TO DO WHAT THEY USUALLY DO:
LIE TO US.
JOE BIDEN JUST CLAIMED ON CAMERA
THAT RIGHT WING INSURRECTIONISTS
AND RACISTS KILLED THE CAPITOL
POLICE OFFICERS.
HE WAS MURDERED AT A CHECK-POINT
BY A SUPPORT FROM THE NATION OF
ISLAM.
>> 3 MONTHS AFTER JANUARY 6TH,
THEY ARE STILL CORDONNING OFF
THE CAPITOL BECAUSE OF THREATS
BY THE SICK INSURRECTIONISTS ARE
RISING ON THE INTERNET.
ALL OF AMERICA SAW WHAT
HAPPENED.
WHEN OFFICER EVANS WAS KILLED
DEFENDING THE CHECK-POINT TO GET
TO THE CAPITOL.
>> Tucker: EVIL AND SECRECY USED
TO BE OBVIOUS TO ALL AMERICANS.
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW AND
TRANSPARENCY IS THE ONLY
SOLUTION.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE WILL GET SOME
THANKS TO SPEAKER KEVIN MCCARTHY
AND A SM